hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number 166 I am Dr
Brett Weinstein this is Dr Heather
highing 166 is not a prime number on
multiple grounds and uh
there's a lot that we uh we need to
cover I will say I forgot to mention
this to you I am
going to make a reversal not a complete
reversal but a partial reversal of a
position that I have previously taken on
today's stream yes excellent I am
changing my position
on the announcement of one's pronouns
yes the announcement of one's pronouns
let me just say that uh
in general I have found that I am so
good at guessing people's pronouns
um that it is unnecessary that people
announce them yes but I am now
cautiously in favor of the announcing of
the pronouns of a cat upon first meeting
so you know
what sex cat you're dealing with
without
um is this based on the piece that I
just published
I don't think so no no you haven't read
it no no uh oh that's embarrassing
um
no okay well I'm now excited to read
that piece to find out how it connects
to the so what prompts what so I I begin
this is from uh not this week's uh
Natural Selections but last weeks I
begin with a true story about having
interacted with a friend of ours young
son uh some number of years ago uh when
we were looking across the yard and I I
asked him oh what sex is your cat
maybe both
I said no cats aren't like that and he
called me a liar
I remember this story no I was just
prompted uh to to this thought by
realizing that I'm not entirely
convinced I'm betting there are cases in
which somebody has gotten a bad
diagnosis of their cat's sex early in
life and have probably uh had the cat
for its entire life without coming to
understand what was truly going on I
mean you know you have in your own
family some bad diagnosis of of cat sex
uh trying to remember well I believe uh
we will presumably hear about if I'm
wrong that uh back during the uh the
Gulf War
your parents came into possession of a
cat whom they named storm and Norman oh
and storm and Norman there turned out to
be a female cat so they changed the name
to Norma right yes storminorma yeah yeah
yeah am I am I no no I believe that
story is completely accurate and uh I do
think that this I feel like you came
unprepared today it's an excellent
demonstration of the need to announce a
cat's pronouns upon first meeting which
was really my point um so you think the
cats should now be announcing their
pronouns is that the idea to the extent
possible sure but if they can't do it I
wouldn't mind somebody else stepping in
and actually am I a placard of some sort
like a sure or you know some sort of a
you know a flag on a hat or something
but
um
that's fine you know yeah I just think
we're not shorts too already
I don't think a cat would put up with
shorts hats okay yeah all right well
this is off to weird stuff
indeed
um
indeed it is yeah indeed it is oh man it
is almost spring here in the Northern
Hemisphere and he at least in the San
Juan Islands Where We Are
man it feels like the season changed
like two days ago instantly two three
days ago like just the light feels
different the it just ah everything is
coming alive and it feels great
um and you know there are people for
whom winter is their favorite season and
you know all of this and we'll say I'm
gonna put you guys aside for the moment
they're all the rest of you for those of
you in the southern hemisphere I'm I'm
sorry but uh we we are here in the
northern hemisphere it is it is
happening spring is coming then summer
lovely well I was actually uh of a
similar mindset and I was going to point
out that this is our last winter
podcast for the year and I was going to
suggest nope won't be
sure it will
well winter begins on the 21st of
December and they will almost there
being more than seven days beyond the
21st of September we'll probably have a
podcast uh at the very beginning of
winter
um we are exiting the winter season and
we will do so on the Equinox which is
the 20th this year this year it is yes
so this will be our last
winter podcast us us being exiting of
the season
yeah this is the calendar year however
uh will end at the beginning of winter
not on the for on oh got it yeah all
right I was not making an astronomical
error I was making a uh a clerical error
um the clerics having defined the
calendar rather oddly from my
perspective but okay in any case my
suggestion was going to be that for
those who will miss the winter Dark
Horse podcasts all you got to do is move
to the Southern Hemisphere and you got
another
several months of them coming three
months in fact but not right away
right you got a few days starting with
that starting
um
starting in it's today's the 18th
starting in two days there will be no
winter broadcasting possible on this
planet for three months
that is correct yes yes yes oh that's
good yeah all right well so we have
worked our way to Clarity which is what
we do in this family and on this project
I think we did no I think we did and uh
it was painful but you know you know
it's not about the journey it's about
the destination and we got there
so this week for the first time in three
weeks we are going to follow this live
stream with a q a which you know after
that remarkable display I don't know
that anyone is going to want to stick
around but if you do if you have
questions ask them if somehow despite
all that Clarity you still have cues
then we will we will a them yeah and um
and then there's another way to ask us
questions also which is that we do a
monthly private q a in my patreon right
now the question asking period is open
at my patreon so consider joining uh us
there we do a joint monthly private q a
and you have conversations at your
patreon you have one tomorrow in fact
yes right so those those are um are good
ways to um to join us in other in other
venues there's also a Discord server
that is available at both of our
patreons where they have karaoke and
happy hours and book clubs and all sorts
of Awesomeness uh you can also read
about
um uh a confused child and his feelings
about cats at my Natural Selections uh
this week I published something this is
just this is it's always surprising me I
feel like something that I called how
now cow of brown
um which I I guess you know it worked
because it took off it became one of by
far the most popular pieces that I've
ever published and I really did not see
that coming so
um I love that title I you know I think
the title went a long way yes it's a
great title because it's a terrible
title I love that about it right right
so it's it's an exploration not of
pronouns but of adjectives and word
order and how the freaking language
police would have us believe that by
changing by Brute Force by dictot uh you
know Standard English usage we are
somehow going to solve the problems of
the world which of course a were not B
that's not how language works and see
what the hell guys come on grow up and
you know get a clue point of order yes
are all language police bastards
well see I I think this is another
reason that this piece was as popular as
it was is that I actually created a
little graphic uh hashtag defund
language police oh you did oh wow we are
on
parallel wavelength and I'm just days
behind feeling that you haven't met
anything I've been posting for a while
well at least for the week yeah and last
week
the last two weeks all right
all right the admissions are flying Fast
and Furious
yes so yes
um uh all language cops may be bastards
I I had that actually in the piece and I
took that out I went like you know what
hashtag defund language police not the
actual police and then we can talk and
you know then we can talk that we can
actually talk and then let's get down to
business talking about how to actually
solve some of the problems of the world
as opposed to all of this
um you know acts of Y stuff instead of
um using language using English the way
uh that English
is used which is to say adjective first
then noun all right so that piece is
there what I believe there's just no way
for me to elegantly deal with this at
the moment I believe you have a small
piece of lint and I think it's going to
be on your right side right about here
we go
okay all right
I didn't see it I think it may have been
in your head but we'll hear about that
okay we can go back to the instant
replay you'll see it was not a figment
of my imagination wait so you've okay
let's do it
oh we can't oh instant replay no
delayed Replay by several hours but um
nonetheless can be done so well can be
done okay
um
so I also on Natural Selections this
week went back and recorded audio of
both how now okay oh Brown and uh he me
she they and also apparently we're the
Bad Guys which uh was another
um surprise hit uh in which I detail
some by no means all of the positions
that we have had over the pandemic uh
and uh just sort of laid them out and
said okay
um these are these are some of the
things we've talked about an incredible
string of uh being right by accident for
the wrong reasons and through total
guesses is that uh precisely yeah yes
precisely
all right
um
maybe it's time to go to our sponsors we
are grateful uh for our sponsors we
start off after whatever this was
um with three ads at the top of the show
and here we go foreign
our first sponsor this week is mud water
one of our favorites mud water makes a
fantastic drink it's spicy and delicious
and chock full of medicinal mushrooms
and other goodnesses with a seventh
caffeine as a cup of coffee you get
energy without the anxiety Jitters or
crash of coffee it can be thought of as
a coffee alternative but it's way more
than that if you like the routine of
making and drinking a cup of warmth in
the morning but don't drink coffee or
are trying to cut down try mud water if
you are looking for a different way to
kick off your day a delicious warming
enhancing way that isn't just a caffeine
Rush try mud water each ingredient was
added with intention it has cacao and
chai lion's mane mushrooms cordyceps
Shaga and reishi turmeric and cinnamon
and it's not the quarter soaps that'll
get into your brain and make you climb
something and then spray the forest yeah
it's not it's not that it's a different
yeah I promise they promise and I mean
I've been drinking mud water and it
hasn't happened to me yet so I noticed
it and I would have yeah yeah so this is
this is the greatest yeah
um it's a incredibly diverse Kool-Aid
cordyceps yeah yeah mud water not so
much so actually you know actually yes
mud water also makes hey a non-dairy
creamer out of coconut milk and MCT and
a sweetener out of coconut palm sugar
and lacuma which is the fruit of an
Andean tree which was used by the Inca
and you can add those they're not
they're non-dairy creamer their
sweetener if you
if you like or you can mix and match add
a bit of their coconut milk and MCT
creamer with some honey from bees real
bees or use mud Waters lucuma and
coconut palm sugar sweetener and skip
the bees entirely if the bees don't make
you feel comfortable
we've added mud Waters coconut milk and
MCT cream at other hot drinks as well
and it's delicious
mudwater's flavor is warm and spicy with
a hint of chocolate Masala chai which
includes Ginger and cardamom nutmeg and
cloves it's also delicious blended into
a smoothie try it with banana and Ice
milk or milk like substance mint and
cacao nibs mud water is 100 USDA organic
non-GMO gluten-free vegan and kosher
certified and it allows you to build a
morning ritual that promotes sustained
energy without the crash visit
mudwater.com Darkhorse to support the
show and use code Dark Horse Mud at
checkout for 15 off that's m-u-d-w-tr
mudwater.com Darkhorse use Dark Horse
Mud at checkout for 15 off you do not
have to be a vegan or even to associate
with vegans year or kosher or
gluten-free or um
I don't even know what it would mean to
be not non-GMO
you yourself don't have to be not
genetically modified to appreciate this
product wow which means you can be
genetically modified and still
appreciate mud water wow which I think
you will regardless of how modified you
are our second sponsor this week is
House of macadamias that's macadamia
nuts tree nuts are delicious and
nutritious they are generally high in
fat and low in carbohydrates unlike what
various food pyramids and government
agencies might have led you to believe
high fat low carb foods are increasingly
understood to be both satiating and good
for you but each species of nut is
different and for many of us macadamias
are the best macadamia nuts take a very
long time to grow however and because
they are both rare and highly sought
after they have the dubious distinction
of being the world's most expensive nut
between the taste and the health
benefits though they're worth it they
have even fewer carbohydrates than most
other nuts for instance half of what
cashews or pistachios have and
two-thirds of what almonds have which
makes them perfect the perfect snack for
breaking a daily fast and controlling
blood glucose they're also uniquely rich
in omega-7s including especially
palmettoic acid an unsaturated fat that
has been linked to Natural collagen
production fat loss and heart health
and um
yeah fat loss and heart health not fat
health and heart loss because that would
be bad that would be bad yeah either one
um I'm in fat health
that yeah okay I don't even know what
that one means House of macadamias is
intent on making this amazing food
accessible to everyone they have
partnered with more than 90 farmers in
Africa and now make one of a kind vegan
again keto and paleo snacks these
include their dark chocolate dipped
macadamias and a delicious assortment of
bars made with 45 macadamia nuts and
flavors favors flavors including salted
caramel and chocolate coconut but our
favorite product of theirs are the
simple salted macadamias made with
namibian sea salt they are amazing we
love them and think that you will too
our house of academias Highly recommends
House of macadamias for all of your
macadamic needs looking for something to
nourish and energize you while in
pursuit of the truth or while climbing
the next Summit go to
www.houseumacademias.com and use code
Darkhorse for a 20 discount on every
order plus dark course listeners will
receive a complimentary four ounce bag
of macadamias when they order three or
more boxes of any Macadamia product once
again that's House of macadamias.com use
code Darkhorse for 20 off every order
you won't be sorry
so I wonder who discovered the macadamia
nut and whether they were capable of
retiring on that contribution to
humanity kind of like the bacon-wrapped
date the first person to do that you
feel like they contributed enough much
more than most people do and it should
have been sufficient for them to move
somewhere nice and I don't know look out
at the view right I bet they didn't no I
bet they didn't either yeah right in
fact they were probably uh I actually
don't know I feel like I looked into it
when I was researching macadamias when
we first accepted the sponsor
um I don't remember where they're native
and but I assume wherever they are
native
um that they were discovered to be
edible by the people who were first
there as opposed to by mostly the people
who are currently mostly in charge of
selling them yes to us but maybe you
know given that uh they're being formed
in Africa maybe they're native to Africa
although I'm not sure about that I don't
know I would not be surprised if someone
plagiarized a primate for the idea
yeah we do that yeah we sure do all
right we got one more sponsor yes we do
our final sponsor this week is MD
hearing aid MD hearing aid makes high
quality simple and effective hearing
aids for a tiny fraction of what most
hearing aids cost helping bring audio
Clarity and capacity to people who might
not otherwise be able to afford it MD
hearing aid was founded by an ENT
surgeon who made it his mission to
develop a quality hearing aid that
anyone could afford he kept the price
Low by simplifying the product removing
several rarely needed components
and he made a product that aims to fit
so well no one will know you're wearing
it other features include rechargeable
batteries that last up to 30 hours water
resistance and up to three feet of water
in their vault plus model and you don't
need a prescription to get one MD
hearing aid has cut out the middleman so
you buy your hearing aid directly from
the source where audiologists and
licensed hearing Specialists are
available seven days a week everyone can
empathize with what it feels like to be
left out of a conversation that others
are enjoying
here's a testimonial from a friend of
ours who has substantial hearing loss
and who relies on hearing aids we asked
her to try this product and here's what
she said quote with my particular type
of hearing loss a deep male voice in a
noisy room is the hardest situation for
me to hear and understand speech I wore
the MD hearing aid to have a
conversation with a deep voiced man in a
room with a lot of white noise the MD
hearing aid passed the test as my
conversation partner's voice was clear
and understandable at a price point of
under a thousand dollars I was amazed at
how effective they are
MD hearing aid is bringing affordable
hearing to hundreds of thousands of
people people who might not otherwise be
able to afford high quality hearing aids
get Clinic level care for 90 less with
MD hearing aid which offers a 45-day
risk-free trial and money back guarantee
go to mdhearingaid.com and use the promo
code Darkhorse to get their new buy one
get one deal a pair of hearing aids
costs just 149.99 plus Dark Horse
listeners will receive a free extra
charging case 100 value
so head to mdhearingaid.com and use the
promo code Darkhorse to get their new
buy one get one deal a pair of hearing
aids for only 149.99
[Music]
so uh we in in all of that
silliness that we start at the top of
the hour with did not talk about where
we're going to deck right we are going
to start by talking about
um farming and ants
and then we're going to take the natural
segue from there and talk about control
and narratives
and we are going to end with a couple of
stories that we've heard this week uh
that uh should I think give us a bit of
Hope and it all actually ties together
although if you just use if you just
look at the topics that we're talking
about it all sounds
a little bit a little bit diverse and
we'll we'll get some raccoon dogs in
there forward to better or diverse
if you say so
I did and there's nothing I can do about
it now I can't take it back even if I
think that would be wise can we get that
instant replayer or not so much
severely delayed replay yes potentially
okay
um
so I was recently
researching
ants leafcutter ants for some
presentations that we were given a
couple weeks ago
and uh and looking into the question of
the evolution of farming in leafcutter
ants and what the comparisons are if any
uh to the evolution of farming in humans
and one of the comparisons is well
humans uh
originated farming many many times
across the world in fact in China alone
there are two different evolutions of
farming there's at least
um there's at least one origin in Europe
maybe more a couple in the New World
um several
um you know several all over the world
but it's always it seems within like
about 10 to 12 000 years ago 12 000
years ago is about as far back as we
think farming goes uh there was some uh
domestication happening before then but
agriculture is 10 12 000 years ago in
each of the places that it happens
independently whereas ants
started farming
um 50 million years ago they've had a
bit of a head start on they definitely
thought of it they definitely well they
definitely yes I
funny of course to say it that way but
of course one of the big differences you
know one of the reasons that we have
been able to you know catch up and in
some ways you might say surpass them in
terms of the diversity that we have uh
employed our farming uh with is that of
course for them presumably it's entirely
genetic right
they're little robots uh running around
doing their thing and it's working for
them and it's working for the fungus
that they are farming
on the leaves that they are cutting and
carrying and growing the fungus on a
substrate but they are not uh learning
in real time right to you know how how
to farm better or different things or
anything and so there's a lot of course
to be said about uh about
this but there was one paragraph in this
really remarkable paper a really long
like a monograph in
um
in a book called insect fungal
associations ecology and evolution a
piece by Schultz at all from 2005 is
when this book was published called
reciprocal illumination a comparison of
agriculture in humans and so the
comparison is okay we have these 18 ants
who've been farming for 50 million years
50 million years five zero million years
and humans who've been farming for 10 to
12 000 years and uh what you know what
are some of the comparisons uh so so
question yeah
um are in this are you going to describe
that farming uh or should we do that in
advance if you're reading this go for it
um so uh the the basics of the farming
involve the removal of pieces you've
undoubtedly seen pictures of ants which
have cut a kind of fingernail-shaped
piece of a leaf they do this from canopy
trees they bring them one piece at a
time in large numbers down into to an
underground cavity where they grow a
fungus which is uniquely adapted to this
Association it grows on the leaves
because the ants are animals they
actually do not for whatever reason have
the chemical capacity to break down the
leaves directly fungus for whatever
reason are much better at uh Advanced
Feats of organic chemistry and they are
able to break down the cellulose and
other components of the leaves and so
essentially the ants facilitate the
growth of the fungus and they eat the
fungus and
this is clearly mutualistic interaction
with many fascinating offshoots and
other features indeed and there are
there are many stages of agriculture in
these ants the leaf Cutters being you
know by our estimation with our
anthropomorphic lens on it the Pinnacle
of atyne Agriculture of ant agriculture
sure but there are there are many stages
that are you know less tightly symbiotic
there are pathogens that are also
co-evolved with you know with this
fungus ant coevolutions you know it's
it's just
story just goes more and more amazing
the deeper you go but this is not going
to be that that story here the paragraph
I want to read from this paper Schultz
at all 2005 and I'll have you show my
screen when I'm when I'm ready to read
it here
just talks about the question of
um where who has the control so with
humans
we imagine that okay well we're the
farmers therefore you know the the crops
that we have domesticated be they plant
or animal or in some cases fungus or
clearly under our control we are the
Masters and uh you can similarly look at
ants and guess the same thing
and there's some evidence with regard to
the ants given what the what we can tell
50 million years is a long time for this
Association to be happening so it's hard
to know it's impossible to know exactly
what the ants 50 million years ago who
were not farming look like and what
they're eating but all evidence suggests
that they were basically eating
arthropods insects live and dead and the
advantages to the fungus and to the ants
for going into this sort of forming
relationship
um it seems like there's some evidence
that actually the fungus might have had
um more of a drive to end up being in
this association with the ants than the
ants did which raises questions about
control I mean you know who's actually
in control here and when you think you
see a system in which one or the other
person organism system whatever it is
it's like control maybe look more
closely look from a different angle and
find that actually control has a lot of
different levers and a lot of different
ways of manifesting itself so let's go
with this uh this paragraph here and
I'll just put it on the screen so people
can read along that did not work
um
and if it doesn't uh it doesn't work
let's try one more time get that plugged
in it is plugged in still
nope
it's very blue okay well I'm going to go
ahead and unplug that so that I do not
risk my computer suddenly showing up uh
and I will just read it off the screen
and I'll link to a link to this in the
show notes again from Schultz at all
2005.
we suspect that most readers will resist
our suggestion that human
agriculturalists were once under the
partial control of their
proto-domesticates during the early
evolutionary process that ultimately led
to human agriculture
human intuition suggests that we are not
under the control of the cabbages and
tomatoes that we plant in our backyards
the cabbages cannot facultatively escape
from our Gardens and from their
inevitable Destinies of death in our
kitchens and that cabbages have not
enslaved us to labor on their
evolutionary behalf
human intuition can be misleading
however we know for example that human
symbionts can sometimes induce profound
behavioral changes in humans that
benefit the symbiont the rabies virus
induces drastic aggressive behavior to
facilitate its spread to new potential
hosts and coca plants induce in humans
of physical addiction and a craving for
more coca which requires the cultivation
of more cocoa plants
though seemingly far-fetched and in
conflict with our intuitions we can at
this point rule out similar
manipulations during the
pre-agricultural evolution of humans a
stage when humans began to assemble the
behavioral repertoires that ultimately
led to agricultural systems Guided by
human planning and intentional
experimentation
this
I wanted to just put out there
for people who have not
even farming much thought give an ant
farming much thought and agriculture
much much thought as a way as a
different way in
to being able to question
of any system that you think you
understand
who is actually
pulling the strings who's actually
calling the shots
um yeah I want to uh there's one thing
in that paragraph that I find troubling
the use of rabies as an example right
after the term symbiotics is clearly not
it's in my aunt yep um and so you know
I think it's a very worthy explanation
yeah so symbiant it's not um but is it
um is it able to exert a behavioral
influence on us of course it is of
course and you know the case of uh Coca
is a better example where it is likely a
mutualism
um and there are many examples of uh
human mutualisms there are plants which
are only known from Human cultivation
which suggests that uh an ancestor uh
changed radically in order to partner
with humans
um what are you thinking uh Salvia
um
so there's lots of salvians but the
Salvia that is used
um as a psychoactive as an engine uh in
central Mexico is only known from The
Gardens of the the population that
utilizes its fascinating uh plant
um there is a a euphorb in Madagascar
which is only known from Gardens it's
not clear whether that's a mutualism or
whether it's simply gone extinct in the
wild and been preserved by people but in
any case there there are a number of
examples
and
I do think you know evolutionarily I
would say the real question
effectively what you have to realize is
that a mutualism tends to start as a
parasitism and a parasitism that does
not harm but in fact in some indirect
way helps the creature being parasitized
is almost immediately immutualism and
because the creature that is being
parasitized but oh it ends up being in
that positive thing then becomes
augmented to facilitate this interaction
and you know if you think about the the
the classic case of something like a
hummingbird
um you know taking nectar and
transporting pollen for a flower to
which it is adapted
it seems like oh they're cooperating but
of course the hummingbird is truly
indifferent to the well-being of the
plant
um at least first order and at least
first order at least first order and the
plant is indifferent to the hummingbird
they're each taking advantage of each
other and because they are both getting
a benefit that outweighs the cost that
they are paying we say oh it's a
cooperation and there's nothing wrong
with that in fact well the tighter the
cooperation the tighter the need right
right so I mean this this will be the
thing that maybe isn't obvious to people
who haven't considered for instance a
hummingbird plant affiliation which is
that you know the more
tight the for instance Corolla of the
flower is the particular recurve nature
decrimp nature can't remember which is
which of the hummingbird's beak uh the
the more both of those species actually
depend on the other in order to make it
into the future right have their genes
make it into the future and they're you
know there's a lot of nuance here it can
be that the plant is uh obligate with
respect to what pollinator it needs and
that the pollinator might be a
generalist in some cases there can be
cases where the relationship is obligate
on both sides but in any case
at some point where a mutualism has
occurred we are effectively defining the
mutualism based on the fact that both
parties are benefiting from what might
otherwise be a one-way parasitism but
that is in some sense our projection
onto it
and in any case you know it's clear that
these ants uh and I actually I wish we
did have the ability to show your screen
you could show some pictures of this but
these plants are a major
force uh in these plants these ants okay
Major Force in the habitats where they
are
um doing their farming they're actually
significantly altering the amount of
photosynthetic capacity of the trees
that they're utilizing
um and so that they're they're
tremendously powerful ecological
phenomenon and
um what that also means is that this
huge amount of productivity that the
that the trees were producing that the
ants had no access to directly they have
found a way to access it through What
Might Have Been a parasite on their
ancestors but it turned out to be
beneficial right in other words
um you know you could imagine a fungus
growing inside I'd have no idea if this
is the proposed mechanism but you know
that there might have been a fungus
growing inside the effectively Caverns
that these animals created maybe it was
growing on arthropods maybe it was is
you know I I'm not sure what it was and
you can imagine maybe ants had uh you
know tunneled into some place where
there was Leaf matter or something and
some fungus is breaking down the leaves
you could see how you could get to a
place where actually feeding the fungus
would uh emerge from The Accidental fact
of a fungus
growing on on cellulose
um but at the point that we arrived
currently and we look at this highly uh
interwoven set of adaptations right you
have a fungus that can't grow without
the ants you've got ants that are
utterly dependent on the fungus that
you've got behaviors in which that's
true Aegis and I had not said that
um at at this point the fungus that the
ants are farming is obligately in
association with ant fungiculture it
does not exist outside of the ant
fungiculture which is remarkable it is
remarkable and so then that leads to
this consideration right I'm
always troubled by people's sense that
um you know vegetarianism is a favor to
the creatures
that we eat it is no such thing
especially for the creatures that we
cultivate in large numbers right
chickens are far better off uh
evolutionarily than their jungle fowl
ancestors cows are far better off than
their wild relatives
um just by virtue of the amount of
control that humans exert on the
ecosystem and so although it's
counterintuitive to us so
the place that you will get dragged for
saying that is that you haven't defined
better off you are talking about
evolutionarily better off
individuals might also be but not in a
factory farming situation oh and this
that is the place where I would argue
that the harm to the individual animals
at the level of suffering is so great
that even though evolutionarily even the
factory farmed animals are certainly in
a better position that morally we are
obligated to
um to confront that problem to end that
practice but
you know just as you know we're all
going to die
it does not no I swear it's true
um that does not cause you it does not
invalidate your life right it does not
make you not want to live while you're
here likewise an animal that is going to
be slaughtered for food is not you know
a
non-animal it's an animal with a known
end of its life just as a salmon uh
Pacific salmon has a known end of its
life right after it reproduces
um so anyway the point is we need to
rethink these things because from the
you know
perspective of the organisms in question
the interests are not intuitively
obvious to us humans well I think I
think one of the pieces you didn't say
there is that um most of our
domesticated
food animals most of those individuals
if not all of those individuals would
not exist but for the fact of our having
domesticated them so the fact that they
will die in service of being eaten by
humans
basically starts starts the analysis too
late if you're really if you're
concerned about the lifespan of the
individual consider that the individual
never would have existed at all never
would have existed at all
yep and that that's exactly it
um and
um so anyway when we get back to the
ants what we've got is an obligate
relationship and that obligate
relationship is clearly
great for the ants and it is you know
clearly great for the fungus in fact
it's so great that both of them have
evolved to become completely dependent
on it and so at this point there's no
point in looking at the relationship and
saying who's you know who who's driving
they're both driving right
um but it doesn't mean if you traced it
back far enough you would almost
certainly find a parasitism that turned
out to have a benefit for the victim and
therefore a mutualism Grew From it and
you know
is it is
statistically very unlikely that two
clades two individuals to any things
coming together
that end up in a Cooperative have
exactly the same moment of hey here it
is this is this is what we're going to
do right so almost always and we can
basically say really almost almost
always if not always
one of those individuals or clades or
entities will have made a move first
will have had an advantage first will
have seen the opportunity first right
and it this is I was actually having a
parallel thought actually
um the way to see this clearly is the
Romantic analog of this right because a
you can see that individuals are
motivated to get involved romantically
by a very powerful kind of self-interest
which is so powerful that it uh
predisposes them to a kind of mutualism
but the
let's take the case of uh
to randos right considering whether to
get romantically involved right you make
it sound so awesome uh yeah I'm trying
I'm trying to uh to not impose anything
one way or the other on it
um a guy
uh trying to bed a gal is actually
involved in a parasitic Behavior now in
modern times it may not be this way
because it may be that he you know his
conscious mind full well understands
that she is going to control whether or
not she gets pregnant and so there's no
real parasitism possible at that level
but a guy trying to bet a gal pre
um uh birth control right is effectively
attempting to inflict a pregnancy on
somebody who will then invest all of the
labor in raising an offspring that is
only 50 related to her that's parasitism
right however the possibility of a
relationship that is reproductive and
worthy of both Partners right the point
is that would be parasitism is adjacent
to a obvious profound mutualism in which
two people decide to team up on the
raising of Offspring and the creation of
a home and all of those
um things and you know we sometimes hear
people almost jokingly talk about the
um
a fetus being a parasite on the mother
which is not correct but it is actually
half correct in the case that the father
has not stuck around right because the
female has been put in the position of
raising an offspring you know she's
divided her genome in half
fused it with a half a genome from
somebody else and if that guy skips out
then the point is the half the genome
that isn't related to her that she is
raising that is uh she is effectively in
forced into a degree of altruism raising
this other half a genome but if they
partner then it is not that at all right
then the point is yes she's only you
know her Offspring is only 50 related to
her but
um the guy is putting in enough effort
that the point is she can actually raise
twice as many many of them and she
recovers that as As a matter of a
mutualism so anyway now we've taken all
the fun out of uh sex romance and all of
that stuff but the idea that there is an
exact map
of this sort of tension between
parasitism and mutualism over in human
romantic space is it's really profound
once you see it
indeed I thought you were going to go
into genomic imprinting space but maybe
that's that's a bridge too far for today
yeah I think I think uh you've done
enough enough of the drive sucking the
fun out of romance biology for uh for
one afternoon but maybe a future episode
um so
we thought we'd start there just to
raise issues of raised Consciousness
questions of when you see interactions
uh between two players let's say let's
just leave it vague entities uh who
appears to be control who appears to be
driving who appears to be conscious who
appears to be making decisions that
benefit them isn't it's not always what
it seems and that is in service of what
you want to talk about uh next around
issues of narrative control yeah so I
wanted to add one more thing which I
think is a good transition not always
what it seems right
in the case of ants right the Queen the
queen is named as if she is the boss of
everybody else and it's not obvious that
that was actually a proper description
yes the colony is acting in service of
the queen but in some sense she is as
much a slave of the colony as she is its
director she is not actually in a
position
to dictate what the ants do it is this
underlying uh genetic fact of their
close relatedness that causes them to
behave in such a way that this queen who
is totally hobbled by her she's just an
Egg Factory yeah she's just producing
mostly mostly daughters some some Sons
but mostly daughters all of whom are
more closely related to each other than
they are with their mom if they're full
sebs and uh she's just pumping out eggs
when they're fertilized their daughters
when they're not fertilized their sons
and and it's just that's that's what
she's doing and you can you can get a
totally wrong idea in fact I had the
um once in a lifetime pleasure of
watching a uh a colony of these um these
ants these farming ants move from one uh
one burrow to another and probably that
was a result of the fact that something
had gotten in and they needed to move
and to escape a parasite but I watched
them uh Hubert uh hubby who was on BCI
when I was there studying leafcutter
ants
knew that the move was happening and he
and I went and uh filmed it but anyway
the point was the queen was being moved
right we saw the queen being moved
should be
was so distorted by her reproductive
role she couldn't even walk right she
was literally being carried and you can
imagine that early you know scientific
appreciators of these ants might look at
it's like a queen and a litter being
escorted to her new uh her new
um Nest but that's really that's a
projection of a human construct that is
really not very similar right
she is a reproductive slave of the
colony as much as anything else so
which then brings us to your transition
about things not being necessarily what
they seem and the confusions surrounding
um corruption and narrative control in
in our modern modern circumstance
so let's explore that a little bit I was
prompted to think of this by
um we will only be here briefly but uh I
watched the most recent interview of Sam
Harris and he once again makes all of
the same uh what I would say are
decidedly wrong points but uh the point
that in the case the 97 percent I think
is the number he uses of your experts
agree and three percent
uh disagree that yes of course it's
always possible that the non-experts are
right but you should go with the 97
percent of the experts each and every
time because you're um
you're much more likely to be correct in
your thinking and so that's obviously
nuts or I should say it the fact is
obviously nuts but why it's nuts isn't
so obvious and I thought it was worth us
exploring that a little bit
so
um
first of all let me just recall
something that we've talked about here
before which is
um that
it is a if the resp the return on
investment for betting Against The
Fringe is pretty reliable right in
general The Fringe isn't right and
um even when it is right it's that
something within the Fringe is Right
while the majority of The Fringe remains
wrong right the fringiness of The Fringe
uh is in and of itself reason to just be
a little skeptical that's certainly true
but what Sam's assertion does not take
into account is a the
disproportionate benefit of knowing when
something on The Fringe is actually
right in spite of the belief of 97 or 99
or effectively 100 of the experts right
in those cases where the experts have it
wrong The Profit to be made is huge
that's one thing
but the other thing is
there's a question about
what that 97 percent even is right under
normal circumstances if everybody was
perfectly free to believe whatever they
wanted and you the experts were having
vigorous discussions in which they were
pushing each other around and had
arrived somewhere naturally
then that's not perfect evidence that
they've got it right but it's at least
something but we don't live in a normal
era and this is really I think what's
driving Sam mad in front of our eyes is
that he is applying rules from some
other time and place as if they are
Universal and they are far from
Universal
so
um
what I wanted what I thought was that it
was worth laying out a kind of taxonomy
of uh
of narrative Brokenness right and
looking at what underlies
um
the uh the differences between times and
places and what we ought to put how much
stock we ought to put in the belief of
so-called experts
so I
everybody realizes that we have a degree
of corruption Sam would acknowledge in
fact he repeatedly does acknowledge
um that
that there is corruption in our
institutions and that that's a problem
but the problem is that the word
corruption itself suggests that it is
the minor Force right if we say that you
know you have an SD card and there's
it's corrupted we're not saying that
most of what's on the SD card is wrong
we're saying that there is a small
disruption somewhere right and that
small disruption may be enough to
prevent your camera from reading it
right or it may distort a photograph or
you know photograph may not be viewable
but the point is the corruption is the
minor part
and the question is are there things
that would cause the Distortion to be
the major part
um so okay corruption is like you know
let's try this
in the case that the interests of some
entity that could corrupt the system are
aligned with the interests of the public
in other words if you have a democracy
where the interests of the public are
supposed to to guide
and you have some Corporation and it
wants something done that would actually
be good for the public there's no
problem it doesn't really have to do
anything it can just make the argument
and the public seeing its own interest
will be in support of the thing
that works for the corporation
what that means is that the efforts that
these corporations deploy the expensive
efforts like lobbying for example those
efforts will be in places where their
interests diverge from the public
right it will corrupt the government not
where it doesn't need to do that it will
corrupt the government where it wants
the government not to do the
government's job serving the public but
instead to serve the corporate needs and
so it will disguise those things as if
they are in the interest of the public
I'm a steel man just one one piece of
this which is that
um
lobbying could be simply about getting
the word out so even you know even under
circumstances where all the interests
align which will be somewhat rare you
might still have things like promotion
marketing advertisement lobbying in
order to spread the good word frankly
um I agree at a technical level
um the the problem with that I mean you
you've said you're steel Manning it so I
know you're not advocating this as a as
a major uh countervailing Force but the
problem is it doesn't take almost
anything to spread the word if it's in
the interests of people to hear the word
right if uh you're a representative in
Congress and there's some piece of
legislation that would be beneficial to
both your constituents and to some power
Power Player then it doesn't take very
much to get that in front of you because
hey it's a win for you even cynically
it's a win for you to advance the cause
you'll make yourself more likely to be
reelected you'll have greater power at
Etc
um and so likewise you know you can say
look there are two reasons for
advertising to exist advertising exists
to manipulate people into doing things
that they wouldn't otherwise do spending
money they wouldn't otherwise spend or
choosing this thing over that thing
um and you can say well part of
advertising is just getting information
out and the answer is yep but sit in
front of your TV sometime and figure out
what percentage of each ad is actually
about information and what percentage is
about manipulation and you'll realize oh
my goodness the Lion's Share of this
thing is absolutely about manipulating
people and the information you know sort
of squeaks in there every now and again
so I think it's like that it's not that
there's no you know a lobbyist could
potentially just alert a lawmaker this
thing is possible it might be good but
more or less what they do really the
reason they're paid the big bucks is to
pretend that that's what they're doing
while in fact they are incentivizing and
manipulating and lying and all the
things that they're so good at
but okay we got corruption right
corruption takes a system that is
supposed to be rigged around the
interest of the population and it
distorts it right a little bit
then we have the next uh piece of this
taxonomy which is capture right now
capture I want to be careful capture is
a term that often comes with another
term regulatory capture right now in my
opinion that's too narrow regulatory
capture is real and that means that an
industry or a company
has gotten control over some entity that
is supposed to be controlling it right
when a Pharma company gets control of
the FDA right it that has that's the
tail wagging the dog the FDA is supposed
to be protecting us from farm right is
supposed to be exerting control over
them and the reverses happen
um so that's regulatory capture but what
we are seeing is something much broader
than that right because a lot of the
things that have been captured aren't
regulatory right so anyway
when corruption is the minor Force
corruption is the right term capture is
when some entity within the system some
institution or process has been taken
over by something that is supposed to be
subservient to it right and then there's
this next phase where it's not even that
the FDA has been captured by
Pharma but it is actually a whole
network of Institutions that then have
an emergent nature right the FDA has
been captured and the FDA
May Grant uh emergency use authorization
where it shouldn't it may participate in
silencing critics right it may
participate in obscuring harms these
kinds of things these are terrible in
and of themselves but then you find you
know the New York Times playing wingman
you do right and so this is like a whole
Next Level not only are we dealing so
corruption is the minor version where
the major version is still doing what
the system is designed to do but it has
been redirected to a small extent you've
got capture where entire institutions
have been inverted and they are doing
the inverse job they are working for
those they are supposed to be regulating
and regulating those they are supposed
to be working for
and then you have this next level thing
which is the emergence of a network of
Institutions that are captured by one
mechanism or another and what it results
is in a an entire
false narrative about where we are what
we face what the experts believe which
is really the place where the analysis
that says hey let's go with the experts
that usually works right we don't know
what the experts believe because as you
and I keep discovering every time you
have a conversation where you confess
your actual beliefs on these things you
find that people don't hold the beliefs
that they have been espousing right they
to one degree or another have private
suspicions that they haven't been
sharing things that they would get
punished if they said them out loud and
so you know we are living in a Hall of
Mirrors that goes even Beyond a world
where you imagine regulatory capture has
happened right why is the New York Times
participating in the same story that the
captured FDA is advancing right how did
that happen how is there no possibility
of real journalism how does it have to
happen in a tweet thread or on sub stack
right rather than in the New York Times
in the Washington Post and you know the
New York Post or whatever other uh
papers I guess the New York Post has
done a certain amount but it's also been
silenced for doing it
um
all right so that's the general the
general taxonomy
yep and uh you know to your points about
the New York Times playing Wing band we
have a beautiful example this week all
right shall we share some of that this
um I was hoping to share my screen for
some of this so I'm just going to be
reading it and again we will share uh
the links
uh in the show notes but
um The New York Times uh reported
basically raccoon dogs for the win it's
their fault coveted 19 sarsko V2 it's
it's the raccoon dogs after all but not
frozen this time no not frozen it's the
fall of those crazy Chinese people who
trade them now now it's not racist right
to blame the Chinese people and their
trade of wildlife that they definitely
shouldn't be trading now now this is The
Honorable thing so the New York Times
in their article headlined new data
links pandemics Origins to raccoon dogs
Wuhan Market which came out on the 16th
March 16th two days ago the first
paragraph reads an international team of
virus experts
international team of virus experts
an international team of virus experts
said on Thursday that they had found
genetic data from a market in Wuhan
China linking the coronavirus with
raccoon dogs for sale there adding
evidence to the case that the worst
pandemic in a century could have been
ignited by an infected animal that was
being dealt through the illegal Wildlife
trade
and you have to go down pretty far in
the article to discover that the players
involved are a lot of the same players
that we've become familiar with now it's
Christian Anderson leading up the team
he is one of the international members
of the international team of virus
experts and then you have playing sort
of well wingman to the wingman is Angela
Rasmussen
and it just you know the same people
with the same conclusions over and over
and over again and this New York Times
article is actually particularly bad but
as it turns out
let me just part most of it from the
Atlantic so we've talked before about
the Atlantic monthlies reporting on SARS
Kobe 2 which has been abominable and
they've got this small team of three or
four happens to be all women reporters
that are just doing this like gossipy
coffee clutch stuff that sort of sounds
sciency but really never is
the Abominable Snow Job
abominable snow job Indeed
um so it's one of them again
um in the Atlantic writing um and so we
talked about this explicitly uh in
November of 2021 on episode 105 what's
going on at the Atlantic but they are
still at it so here I'm going to and
again wish I could show you my screen
here but we do just some highlighted
sections from the Atlantic article
called the strongest evidence yet that
an animal started the pandemic a new
analysis of genetic samples from China
appears to link the pandemic's origin to
raccoon dogs by Catherine J Wu this was
published somehow the same day as the
New York Times article was published
even though the New York Times cites the
Atlantic as having been the source of
this so see earlier point about the
weird coordination across institutions
yes indeed updated
um the following day that is to say
yesterday March 17th I don't know what
was updated
um but you know there's this whole piece
is
worth reading if you can stomach it but
I've just I'm just going to read the
highlighted the pieces that I've
highlighted here
this re oh actually I'll I'll start with
you know what is the evidence anyway
like what has happened that we are now
so certain that it's raccoon dogs if not
a corgen right it must be powerful
evidence oh it's powerful it's going to
be powerful for three years now the
Oracle Begins the debate this is the
article by Wu in the Atlantic Monthly
published this week for three years now
the debate over the origins of the
coronavirus pandemic has ping-ponged
between two big ideas that SARS kovi 2
spilled into human populations directly
from wild animal source and that the
pathogen leaked from a lab through a
swirl of data obfuscation by Chinese
authorities and political
politicalization within the United
States and rampant speculation from all
corners of the world many scientists
have stood by the notion of this
outbreak like most others had purely
natural roots
but that hypothesis has been missing a
key piece of proof genetic evidence from
the Hunan Seafood wholesale Market in
Wuhan China showing that the virus had
infected creatures for sale there now an
international team of virologists
genomicists and evolutionary biologists
may have finally found crucial data help
fill that knowledge Gap a new analysis
of genetic sequences collected from the
market shows that raccoon dogs being
illegally sold at the venue could have
been carrying and possibly shutting the
virus at the end of 2019. let me just
slow down here a new analysis of genetic
sequences collected from the market
shows that
raccoon dogs being illegally sold at the
venue could have been carrying and
possibly shutting the virus at the end
of 2019. that's the
way okay it's some of the strongest
support yet experts told me that the
pandemic began when SARS Kobe 2 hopped
from animals into humans rather than in
an accident among scientists
experimenting viruses this really
strengthens the case for a natural
origin says SEMA lakdawala apologies for
their pronunciation a virologist at
Emory University who wasn't involved in
the research Angela Rasmussen a
urologist involved in the research told
me this is a really strong indication
that animals at the market were infected
there's really no other explanation that
makes any sense really Angie should I go
on do you want to inter introduce first
before there are a couple there's a lot
more to say but yeah um one the idea
that this is the strongest evidence yet
may actually be true even though there
is really essentially no evidence here
other than the presence of the animal in
the location that they want us to
believe it started in and there's some
and we'll get here but there's some
sequences that have
um the you know the Genome of the
raccoon dog and um The genome of the
virus that show up in the same place
right
right at the same time
ish right the kind of evidence that
implies that the people in the World
Trade Center may have brought it down
themselves because their DNA was present
in the crime scene but you know but also
notice the linguistic turn of phrase
there where the point is what we've been
waiting for is evidence that it came
from the Wuhan lab I mean the the Wuhan
seafood market yes yes that is the piece
that is missing that is the piece and my
God there's so much here
like as far as I can tell like this is
this is the scientific evidence at this
point there's not even a freaking paper
to look at oh there's nothing it's not
it's not oh it's only on a pre-print
server like no it doesn't exist yet well
it doesn't exist yet and yet you have
two major Publications trumpeting it and
we've seen this before with covet we saw
this with the together trial that
supposedly uh showed that Ivermectin was
ineffective against covet where we had
that result six months before we were
able to look at the methodology of the
paper that was trumpeted in major
headlines and so this is not even unpeer
reviewed right you've got peer-reviewed
where something has been scrutinized and
then it is presented to the public
you've got unpreer-reviewed where it's
put on a pre-print server and nobody has
scrutinized it ahead of time
so that other scientists and anyone else
who wants to can assess yes there's no
assessment possible it's not possible
the point is what they've done is
they've decided to give us the
conclusion in advance of us being able
to scrutinize how they reached it which
suggests that that conclusion may not be
based on a robust methodology why would
they want to do that though why would
they want to start with a conclusion
well possible interest could they have
in starting with the conclusion
interesting now some people will
remember that Christian Anderson was in
fact initially the person who called
Anthony fauci's attention to the fact
that the Genome of the virus in question
was in his words inconsistent with
predictions from evolutionary theory
from a natural origin
well he has seen he has seen the light
for those of you just listening I'm
making that gesture that people make
when they're handling money
um
does anyone actually do that with money
though
I have never seen film of Christian
Anderson doing this but there is
actually evidence of a tremendous amount
of money having flowed to him to his
boss Eric tople yes that Eric tople at
the Scripps Institute that's an expert I
can really get behind trusting can't you
um I am I am somewhat behind in trusting
Eric topel I just think he may have a
conflict of interest the size of a you
know the International Space Station but
um but anyway the idea that we are being
told you know that we have multiple
journalistic sources that are reporting
it's so urgent yeah it's so urgent that
we know the conclusion from this study
that they have to publish on it before
we're even allowed to look at it well
that department of energy stuff that
came out and said like actually we're
not sure at all but like it really kind
of seems like it could be a lab leak
they they had to get right on top of
that so here we have these sort of
glowing endorsements in pseudosciency
language and you know the I don't know
the I'm not I have never run into as far
as I know before the work of the author
of The New York Times piece but this
like
the Atlantic just created this stable of
pseudoscience journalists reporting on
pseudoscience that did their work over
and over and over and over again during
this pandemic during the whole for the
last three years and they just haven't
veered they just have not looked outside
of their little their Lane you know they
picked the lane and they are staying in
it and there's nothing to indicate that
that lane is reflective of reality or
truth shall I read a few more bits from
absolutely
it's a long article
um
the genetic sequences were pulled out of
swabs taken in and near Market stalls
around the pandemic start so that's the
source of the evidence
the new analysis led by Christian
Anderson Edward Holmes and Michael Warby
three prominent researchers who have
been looking into the virus's roots
shows that that may not be the
case that not may not be the case being
um
uh sorry uh no animal host for stars
could be 2 can be deduced within about
half a day of downloading the data from
gisaid this is not a database I am
familiar with and so I'm not actually
sure how it's normally pronounced but
gisaid
it's an Open Access genomic database was
Data were posted there and this team
happened to get lucky and pull it and
then the data disappeared again and no
one can figure out what's going on there
so that also is strange maybe everyone
just got lucky
Maybe
within about half a day of downloading
the data from gisa ID the trio and their
collaborators discovered that several
Market samples that tested positive for
SARS Kobe 2 were also coming back chock
full of animal genetic material much of
which was a match with a common raccoon
dog a small animal related to foxes that
has a raccoon-like face
finding the genetic material of virus
and mammals so closely commingled enough
to be extracted out of a single swab
isn't perfect proof Lochte Walla told me
it's an important step I'm not going to
diminish that she said still the
evidence falls short of say isolating
Stars Kobe 2 from a free-ranging raccoon
dog or even better uncovering a viral
sample swab from a mammal for sale at
Hunan from the time of the outbreaks
onset
still the findings don't stand alone
do I believe there were infected animals
at the market yes I do Anderson told me
so this is just a statement of belief
it's not based it's it's simply a
statement of belief it's a statement of
belief do I believe there are infected
animals at the market yes I do Anderson
told me does this new data add to that
evidence base yes end quote the new
analysis Builds on extensive previous
research that points to the market as a
source of the earliest major outbreak of
SARS cov2 colon here's the evidence
she's going to trot out many of the
earliest known covid-19 cases the
pandemic were clustered roughly in the
Market's vicinity
roughly
and the viruses
genetic material was found in many
sample swab from carts and animal
processing equipment at the venue as
well as parts of nearby infrastructure
such as storehouses sewage Wells and
water drains that's
two pieces of evidence neither of which
are evidence not extensive research
raccoon dogs creatures commonly bred for
sale in China are also already known to
be one of many mammal species that can
easily catch and spread the coronavirus
all of this left one main hole in the
puzzle to fill
clear-cut evidence the raccoon dogs and
the virus are in the exact same spot at
the market close enough that the
creatures might have been infected and
possibly infectious that's what the new
analysis provides
they could really use someone who
understands anything
about evolution
or how viruses might actually move
between species don't you think no I
think that would screw up their whole
plan of selling us the idea that the
seafood market is the likeliest origin
of the human pandemic all of this left
DNA of an investigation's main suspect
at the scene of the cross
findings don't rule out the possibility
that other animals may have been
carrying SARS Kobe 2 at one on raccoon
dogs if they were infected may not even
be the creatures who pass the pathogen
onto US
well then why are we talking about them
okay that's not in the article I'm
editorializing now which means the
search for the viruses many wild hosts
will need to plot on do we know the
intermediate host with raccoon dogs no
Anderson wrote to me using the term for
an animal that can vary a pathogen
between other species is it high up on
my list of potential hosts yes but it's
definitely not the only one so now we're
kind of backing off from this giant like
oh the New York Times the Atlantic
Monthly is going to tell us that now we
have this evidence it's raccoon dogs
raccoon dogs well except maybe not but
it could be so we've now backed off
two-thirds of the way or so through this
article too yeah maybe but isn't this
cool
at this point it's still unclear why the
sequences were so recently posted to
gisaid they also vanished from the
database shortly after the international
team of researchers notified the Chinese
researchers of their preliminary
findings without explanation
they go on and on and on there's really
no explanation
Skeptics
will likely be eager to poke holes on
the team's new findings
pointing out I don't think they need to
be poked I think there are plenty of
holes in those findings they don't
require any of us like
we've been sure enough we've had nothing
shared with us there's no findings
except that we've been told
we've been told swabs had DNA from the
raccoon dogs and uh genetic sequences
from the virus in close proximity in a
market where sick people undoubtedly
co-mingled with animals that they were
buying you sound like a skeptic
Skeptics will likely be eager to poke
holes in the team's new findings
pointing out for instance this is
technically possible for genetic
material from viruses and animals stand
up sloshed together in the environment
even if an infection didn't take place
maybe an infected human visited the
market and inadvertently deposited viral
RNA near an animal's crate how dare they
but an infected animal with no
third-party contamination still seems by
far the most plausible explanation for
the sample stranded contents several
experts told me
other scenarios require contortions of
logic and more important additional
proof
I got we're almost there all right
the debate over SARS Kobe 2's Origins
has raged for nearly as long as the
pandemic itself
okay I don't even get the rest of the
sentence outlasting lockdowns widespread
masking even the first version of the
covid-19 of the coveted vaccines
I don't know what that's doing there and
as long as there is murkiness to cling
to it may never fully resolve
when President Joe Biden asked the U.S
intelligence Community to review the
matter for government agencies and the
National Intelligence Council pointed to
a natural origin while two others
guessed that it was a lab leak
okay
finally into this
crap piece in the Atlantic if this new
level of scientific evidence does
conclusively tip the origins debate
toward the animal route it will be in
one way a major letdown
it will mean that SARS Kobe 2 breached
our borders because we once again
mismanaged our relationship with
wildlife
that we failed to prevent this epidemic
for the same reason we failed and could
fail again to prevent so many of the
rest oh I frankly I predicted that
if they manage to sell us on this story
that this has a natural origin then the
point is the lesson of the pandemic is
the inverse not you must not do the kind
of research that turns the world upside
down but in fact you have to do more of
that research because we missed it you
know by this much we were studying these
viruses but we didn't get ahead of this
thing and it got us anyway so next time
we need to have done much more of this
gain of function research in order to be
ready that's what they're going to sell
us it's even worse than that oh yeah all
right my turn yeah yeah no so that for
sure but also don't got into nature
that it's dangerous there's wild things
out there and they will give you
diseases stay inside be safe it's clean
we've got some antibacterial spray for
you antiviral spray anti-everything
spray you just get right in that
comfortable little zone of yours will
stream some crap into your face that you
can watch and be entertained by but for
God's sake don't go outside it's
dangerous yes Don't Unplug from our
mechanism of narrative control
um so I wanted to give an interpretation
you you wondered about their claim of
the uh natural origin having outlasted
something something about uh it just
back themes Mass
et cetera Etc it's just a weird thing to
well but no I know what they're getting
at okay
in this case the day is a she well it's
part of the bigger C earlier Point
regarding the emergent nature of the the
day she uh complex that advances the
phony narrative uh yeah we have to talk
about cats again are we no no no for the
moment no no we're on to
um raccoon dogs having uh wait did they
have pronouns too you'll have to ask
them but I will say that this is a major
Leap Forward from the Frozen ferret
Badger Stakes uh that they failed to
convince us we're the source the Great
Leap Forward and talking about the
origins of this virus
I guess I mean you know
um make of it what you will okay but uh
okay but what really is going on here is
there a couple of narratives that are
disproportionately important and this is
a subtle point I think but
in some cases
we have succeeded in staring down their
garbage narratives right safe and
effective is not a phrase you hear
regularly used about the vaccines
anymore we're into much more nuanced
territory we're still lagging behind the
reality of what is apparent in the data
but
um nonetheless but there are certain
um
they are there are certain narratives
with uh an undead nature to them right
and I in fact would call the kind of
Journalism that you're talking about
instead of burying the lead it's
exhuming the lead they keep resurrecting
uh their lead their lead because they
cannot afford to have it die right to
the extent that the world is keeps
discovering I mean we keep getting new
agencies uh you know people who were on
the commission who uh you know Jeffrey
Sachs uh has announced that he saw
nothing but corruption in the commission
that was trying to find the origins
we've got all of these things that would
ordinarily cause a regular person to say
you know what that Wuhan seafood market
uh explanation
turned out to be nuts all sorts of
people with all sorts of different kinds
of expertise have converged on the idea
that this does seem to have emerged from
the lab right there in Wuhan
um Etc outbreak of chocolatey goodness
right
um but
the point is they can't afford to let it
go and it I don't think that they think
they're going to win this one but I
think what they have to do is muddle it
right this is a this is the doubt
component of a fear uncertainty and
doubt campaign the point is they need to
have some alternative That Remains live
so that the people who have been so
thoroughly embarrassed by the failure of
that garbage narrative have something to
say oh I'm on team Atlantic New York
Times right I mean don't you know that
they found the DNA of the you know uh
they found the DNA of the raccoon dogs
along with genetic material from SARS
Kobe 2 which of course if you're paying
attention you know that at the point
that these things are being swabbed for
in the Wuhan seafood market likely the
disease had been circulating in Wuhan
since September or October of 2019 it's
no surprise that there was SARS cov2 uh
all over the Wuhan seafood market which
means it's going to be co-mingled with
every single organism that was in that
market right there's no evidence here
um
and you know much less something that
they would let us scrutinize but but the
point is that narrative and the
Ivermectin turned out not to work
narrative these are two narratives that
they are never going to let die doesn't
matter what the evidence says they need
both of them right and they've got
um
they've got Confederates like
raspberries and saying this is a really
strong indication that animals that the
market were infected there's really no
other explanation that makes any sense
this is As credentialed on point a
scientist as you could possibly be who
has made a statement that is so
utterly and transparently ludicrous
and yet here it is here it is in the
Atlantic that statement makes no sense
and yet that that Authority saying it
will be sufficient for some number of
people right and it sounds so full of
meaning no other explanation makes sense
how about somebody with covid cough near
a raccooned up I mean I mean how about
even in this terrible article there's
there's other things like even this
terrible article presents others cannot
manage to not admit that actually yes
this isn't the only possibility even
Christian Andersen says
this isn't this isn't Clear Proof yeah
it's the weakest of tea and you know
what's more you know here's some strong
evidence we haven't found the wild
circulating pandemic in any creature let
alone raccoon dogs right so the point is
if you really wanted to find this
evidence look if you know that
maybe they should hire OJ to go look for
it basically right you know he's he
hasn't come up with anything on his
ex-wife's killer right so he's probably
at this point free to go look for the
infected raccoon dogs wow okay I guess
my point is look nobody really expected
OJ to go looking for the real killer
because that would have been a very you
know Annoying experience given what he
apparently well and you know not only
added it's one thing to search in vain
it's another thing to search for
something you know doesn't exist right
precisely and so the point is look we've
had an awful lot of time much longer
than it has taken in any of the previous
cases that are in any way analogous to
this to find the intermediate host and
the point is it's not you know it's not
like we don't know what we're looking
for so I do fear
that somebody is going to cook it up at
some point well and it's interesting too
that you know we have oh you know
Anderson's saying well you know it's
definitely you know at or near I don't
remember exactly what he says here at
the top of my list if possible
intermediate host but I've got a lot of
others it's like oh really tell us
because this is the first I've been
hearing about raccoon dogs and I'm sure
some other people were talking about at
some point but like wasn't it the Frozen
ferret Badger Stakes there for a while
yeah and uh and there are some other
possibilities but
um interesting that in direct contrast
to how science is supposed to happen uh
this is an issue that concerns the
entire planet
and there are a list of possible
intermediate hosts in the head of the
main guy who's got one and only one
hypothesis and he will never ever stray
from it therefore it doesn't make it a
hypothesis really and he's not going to
share that with us
doesn't that make it easier for the
point that they discover some maybe
better evidence that oh actually it's
you know this guy over here it's it's a
Pangolin after all ah yes well that was
on my list on my short list that I kept
private because why like to what end who
wins by that list of possible
intermediate hosts being only in the
head of the person who has a goal to
prove that this was a zoonotic origin as
opposed to from the lab right
um
there's nothing there's nothing here but
I I want to tie this back to
um the taxonomy that we were building
okay because when you get to this
emergent layer right where you've got
narrative control you've got a storyline
that is so fundamental to the power
players getting whatever it is that
they're trying to accomplish protecting
themselves from uh taking the blame that
they rightly deserve for having
triggered This Global catastrophe for
example in order for them to avoid
responsibility they need to preserve
a story like this
they cannot preserve it through any
normal means because any normal Rules of
Evidence would tell you that you
actually don't have any evidence here
there really isn't any evidence of
anything that isn't effectively
automatic yes people will have had SARS
Kobe 2 in that market and they were
selling whatever they were selling right
so the existence of genetic sequences
doesn't tell us one way or another and
as I've pointed out before
you know if there was a coffee shop on
the ground floor of the Wuhan Institute
and somebody went around swabbing it and
found you know evidence of very early
versions of the virus it wouldn't say
that the coffee shop had produced it
point is the coffee shop happens to
exist in close proximity to the lab
which is the very likely source as the
seafood market exists in very close
proximity to the lab which is very
likely the source which is the reason
that it seems to have been circulating
at the Wuhan military games in September
October of 2019. the point is this is
circumstantial evidence where you would
expect there to be circumstantial
evidence it doesn't narrow down the
search at all right right now an
infected uh infected ferret Badger or
infected raccoon dog would a population
of infected raccoon dogs but I mean
again we don't have actually the
scientific evidence in front of us but
the article says actually it's already
known it was already known that
coronaviruses or maybe this one I don't
remember
um you know do circulate in raccoon dogs
like okay that's that's the valuable
piece of information now that doesn't
tell us that it's that it's circulating
the population or that it can it is it
is moving between them no I mean in in
fact to say that you know coronaviruses
are known to circulate in raccoon dogs
doesn't mean anything coronavirus is
circulating people right
um we're talking about a very odd
coronavirus with some very odd genetic
anomalies and the point is you want to
find something that is plausibly a
descendant of an early ancestor of this
virus circulating in raccoon dogs either
in the wild or uh in captivity and you
know again I fear that somebody is going
to cook this up right and we are going
to depend on sleuths to make sure that
it's actually a real instance rather
than something somebody has generated to
get Anthony fauci off the hook yeah but
um let me just I found I found the the
quote yeah
um
from this was again from the Atlantic
monthlies article
published this week
raccoon dogs creatures commonly bred for
sale in China are also already known to
be one of many mammal species that can
easily catch and spread the coronavirus
yeah that's the sentence which written
badly
yes written badly intentionally or
unintentionally who's to say but from
that sentence we cannot tell we do not
know anything the coronavirus is not the
coronavirus there's not the coronavirus
what's more as far as I know that
statement to the extent that it could be
narrowed to something meaningful like
hey here's an animal that actually
transmits this coronavirus isn't right
right it because there are a wide
variety of animals that have contracted
SARS cov2 but in terms of those who are
capable of transmitting it to people the
list is Tiny it's really a raccoon dogs
like mink in this regard which would be
something and
um
boy like
for those who will say well you know why
are you picking on this this is this is
part of the point right
literally there's no science out there
yet there is nothing written that has
been shared publicly
and you know we along with many others
have been taken to task for talking
about
um
papers that are posted on pre-print
servers that haven't yet been peer
reviewed
there is no paper there is no research
there is no write-up there is no ability
to analyze what has happened except for
these two articles both of which are
basically borrowing from one another and
which rely on interviews with with
sources that are known at least in one
case at least in the case of the author
of the Atlantic article to already be
long time friendly with these same
sources who will not stray from their
conclusion regardless of what other
evidence shows up
this is not science it's not science and
you know you can actually one thing that
struck me I read the New York Times
version of this
um was that one of the authors of this
paper that does not exist
is
confident that raccoon dogs existed in
the stall from which these swabs were
taken in 2014 when he happened to be
there
right yeah
I know like really what we
this is it's this is anecdotal nonsense
the idea that that constitutes some kind
of evidence worth reporting in the New
York Times about some paper that we
haven't seen and can't see look we know
right the the cold fusion episode right
the problem was they went to the Press
before there was anything to scrutinize
right we know that this is a No-No
journalistically speaking they shouldn't
do this for a reason now that's very
different than a preprint a preprint in
which at the points at the conclusion
emerges we can also scrutinize the
methodology and that's and it's and it's
and it's good because all of us can
scrutinize it as opposed to oh well it's
been peer reviewed therefore you can
trust that it's already been vetted well
it's been vetted by people who may or
may not have had a perverse incentive to
either actually definitely
um let that get published or definitely
not let that get published right so the
pre-print service I mean we've talked
about this you know three years ago
three years ago and you know two years
and 11 months ago and tears and 10
months ago like you know in the spring
of 2020
it was the Wild West in terms of the
pre-print service and it was amazing
because so much was available I know you
couldn't keep up no you couldn't read
everything just as you can't read all
the stuff that's peer-reviewed but what
you knew was the stuff that was out
there
um that was on preprint servers you
could assess for yourself and maybe you
had the skills and maybe you didn't
but at least it didn't have an
additional level of editorial control
between you and your ability to assess
which
if the editors are great and if the peer
reviewers are great then fine that'll
help that'll help you not have to Wade
through so much of the chaff to get to
the wheat but as we know back to your
point right about the capture and the
corruption and the ways that you have
Wing men effectively playing you know
entities playing wingman to you know the
desire to not have the truth come out we
have
we have a problem that is multivariate
and deeper than I think almost any of us
could have imagined right and you know
there's I did not see any mention of why
it is they were reporting the conclusion
before the emergence of the paper now if
the paper is ready to go enough that
they reporters could have looked at it
and decided for themselves whether it
was worth reporting they could put it on
a pre-print server right and they could
say this paper which is now going
through peer review right but is
available here in its pre-print version
they could have done that and they
didn't do that and that is a tell and
the tell is what we want is the report
in other words the report in the
Atlantic and the New York Times are the
purpose of This research right the
research itself is beside the point and
in fact
stalling and delaying so that we can't
scrutinize it and then predicting that
oh well certainly Skeptics will emerge
geez maybe you did crappy research and
of course you know that the Skeptics are
going to come after you because they're
going to notice that it was crappy
because there's so much writing on it
and there will be lots of scrutiny and
so the point is yeah announce your
conclusion predict Skeptics and then
later on down the road I guess we'll get
to see this paper and find out what
[__] up [__] you actually did
right which is uh
a remarkable place to be the New York
Times and the Atlantic should be calling
[__] on this rather than amplifying
it
um yeah who's
I don't know I was going to say like
whose pocket are you in but like
this isn't what you guys stand for this
this the New York Times you like monthly
this is not what you stand for well this
is not what you
lame to stand for and should be standing
for if you're journalists we need we
need
an open and Free Press and instead we
have sentences like
four government agencies the National
Intelligence Council pointed to a
natural origin while two others guessed
that it was a lab like
pointed
guest
sorry wrong
um one last Point yeah
in this taxonomy right where you go from
corruption to the capture of an
institution to the control over some
larger piece of the system which you
know the journalists are doing the
bidding of the pharmaceutical companies
and the you know corrupt head of uh
governmental agencies Etc there's a
question about how that emergent
phenomenon happens and certainly some of
it right when we scratch the surface and
we see that Kristen Anderson and Eric
topel
um have both been greatly uh enriched
and just so happened to hold positions
that are consistent with the powerful
corrosive entity right we can say oh
well I think maybe I understand that but
then there's lots of people who are a
little hard to explain right and I
wanted to just point out that because
we're dealing with an emergent
phenomenon it doesn't have to abide by a
single mechanism it doesn't have to be
that there's some coordinating entity
that reached out to a bunch of people
and you know figured out who was willing
to do its bidding and
whatever else what it can be is that
people get very good at figuring out
how to get remunerated how to get paid
and paid doesn't have to be in money it
can be in Social credibility it can be
reputation it can be positions at
institutions that are ascendant whatever
opportunities
um but essentially there's like a
gradient of well-being and if you take
certain positions and your life starts
getting better because some powerful
entity takes notice that you are doing
its bidding and it decides to protect
you and reward you and do all of those
things then you can get a vast network
of what I call Freelancers to do the
work for you so in the case of the New
York Times and the Atlantic are we
dealing with people are we dealing with
useful idiots right who don't know that
what they're saying is nonsense are we
dealing with extensions of the entities
that are corrupting and controlling our
system
maybe or are we dealing with Freelancers
who noticed that when they spoke up with
skepticism about the lab leak hypothesis
that things started to go well for them
and when they spoke up in the other
direction things went badly and just
started to do what it was that
effectively this isn't it's selection
right it's selection creating an
emergent uh analog of a conspiracy now
I'm not saying there's no conspiracy
undoubtedly there are many levels of one
here but there's also a lot of stuff
that may well not be conspiratorial it
may be people responding to their
incentives and as you say selection
choosing those who do the bidding of
those uh in the positions of power
indeed
wow okay
um
let's finish up today before we take a
break and then come back for the Q a
with two stories relayed to me this week
by an acquaintance in a major west coast
city I'm sharing these stories with
permission um but I've changed a few
details to preserve the anonymity
of the people involved and so the first
one he suggested The Heading was you
made your bed you have to sleep in it
I'm thinking this is a Two Can Play That
Game uh story so we've got a woman was
interviewing for a job
for which she was qualified and she was
asked if she had been vaccinated against
covid the would-be employer clarified
that while they don't have mandates now
they had had mandates and they wanted to
no uh if she'd been vaccinated
and uh she was offered the job
she turned it down and then telling them
why
said I'm looking for a position that is
inclusive and I want to work for a
company that values diversity
and do not feel given the passcode
vaccine policy at this company that this
company would be a good place for me to
work to experience those values that I
hold so dear
and I think that's that's brilliant uh
let's you know use some of their tools
against them right and this this also
fits with and I wish I could show my
computer here this week but I have shown
before this sign that is at a store in
Sellwood in Portland uh that I have I
haven't been back for a while but I've
seen up for a while including when
everyone was being told you absolutely
100 need to get vaccinated right now and
there are a lot a lot of stores and
restaurants that didn't let you in if
you weren't and they have this sign up
and I'll just read it from my screen it
says we do not discriminate against any
customer based on sex gender race Creed
age vaccinated or unvaccinated all
customers who wish to patronize are
welcome in our establishment
so this is in in that vein so I would
point out that this is The Honorable
Counterpoint to the evolution of
um freelance
propagandists that's right that if we
take care of those who in spite of the
fact that it was difficult to do stood
up for us you know instead of having uh
onerous mandates posted at their door
they posted the opposite and they
invited people in
um you know we should remember those
people even now that those mandates are
gone
um we should recognize them and
patronize their institutions
um because we want a world in which
people stand up it's a better world
that's right it stands a good chance of
functioning
certainly do
okay Second Story
also a west coast city and that's
relevant because
um
you know cities across well across the
west but especially in the United States
Paris is getting that right now isn't it
but
especially in the United States since
the summer of 2020 and I think there
wasn't a city on the west coast a major
city on the west coast that wasn't
spared a lot of the the chaos
um
and
people you know even people who persist
in their in their pre
George Floyd pre-covered beliefs about
what should and should not be happening
at a policy level or looking around
saying you know this isn't safe I don't
feel safe I need to figure out how to
protect myself
so we've got a guy who teaches firearm
skills and um and safety to small groups
of people at a long established gun
range in school and many of his students
who come in come in with no experience
of course but also sometimes they are
vocally anti-gun and
um they feel they have no choice to be
there because they're looking around
their neighborhoods going I actually
need to figure out how to protect myself
but they're they're
they resent it they're Sullen
often these same people who are sullen
who will come into these classes you
know talking being explicitly loud about
I don't want to be here I don't think
guns are a good idea they're there
they're also often masked uh it's not
maybe a huge surprise that those are um
overlapping populations even even now
um but he this instructor reports in a
recent class this again happened and
there were you know small class but a
good portion of the people were you know
started out resentful Sullen you know
vocally resistant to what they were
there doing masked not interacting with
the rest of the people
and that by the end
there was none of that
it disappeared
uh people were laughing together talking
sharing stories learning from each other
everyone take their masks off like
literally and I think figuratively
everyone had taken their masks off and
um the guy who's telling me this says
it's not it's not about the guns it's
not the guns aren't bringing people
together that's not what's going on
he said I I think what it is is
um
about connecting outside of your comfort
zone and interacting with strangers
frankly with people who you didn't know
um who you didn't know before and coming
together around something that is
challenging that is tough that is a real
skill that can be learned but that you
need to focus and and
um
and and pay attention and you can learn
not just from you know the person who's
supposed to be teaching you but from
your peers as well this is broadening
and it's humanizing and it's something
that so many of us
have have missed out on and lost access
to starting just about three years ago
now
yeah the
uh sense that I have is
a whenever we try this thing where we
confess our doubts to people and they
Ante Up by confessing their doubts right
there is a sense a palpable sense of
relief and I have the sense that most
people are living in this tightly
constrained narrative where they know
what they are expected to believe and
they have convinced themselves that that
is what they believe and they say it out
loud and the people affirm them and so
they're living in this sort of
a terrified State yes and the
you know just as there was something
awful about being locked down in our
homes at the beginning of the pandemic
when in fact what we should have been
doing is gathering outside right
Gathering outside
okay so there's a pathogen spreading
inside of buildings but we can go
outside and talk about it and not be
fearful right that sense of relief is so
important and from the uh perspective of
those who wish to main control maintain
control over us it is necessary that we
find ways to break that uh hegemony over
us and I think the the natural human
part is if you if you take that risk and
you do let your guard down and you dare
to say what you actually think
you're actually concerned about the uh
you will paradoxically feel so much
better to discover that you're really
not alone
and I suspect that's what happened on
the gun range yeah I suspect so too and
it's
you know it may seem to some that you
know it's easy for us to say at this
point right
um that you know we
we've been doing it for three years but
you know of course
taking an awful lot of [__] for doing so
and
um
and there's of course the majority of
people in the world
don't don't know what our positions are
when we interact with them uh and every
single time you've just said this but
I'm just going to repeat it like every
single time
that I have been in a situation where
I'm interacting with someone who you
know I'm a stranger to them and they're
a stranger to me uh and uh it's you know
it's a it's a barista it's a waitress
it's a dry cleaner you know it's some
it's a retail it's a cashier you know
Uber driver something right in any
number of of things and
you say something that suggests
anything that isn't in lockstep with
what given the place you're in which is
to say like if you're in a West Coast
City you know what you're supposed to
believe on any number of topics and if
you say something that suggests anything
outside of lockstep
it is
almost Universal that what you get is
burst cautious and then
like a just an outpouring of
conversation
and relief on both sides
and connection
you don't end up getting
glared at and yelled at and hated and
that certainly happens but if you're
taking
as evidence of how people feel what you
see on social media
it's not a good rendering of what is
actually happening in the world yeah
it's actually a a co-opting of a natural
circuit where we're supposed to be able
to assess what people think just based
on our interactions with them and what
is apparent and because the narrative
control is so powerful we get a very
wrong impression about how unified
people are in believing certain things
whether it's in our city or across the
net
um you know I'm also struck as you know
we uh watch The Big Short
again last night just really is a
refresher on what had happened in 2008
um I said to you I think
I think it might be time to re-watch
that movie I was struck actually I can't
really believe I didn't put it together
maybe I've just forgotten but
um you know the the bulk of the movie is
spent in this excruciating period where
the people who had seen what was taking
place in the housing market
placed their bets but the evidence that
they were correct is oddly delayed and
um everybody is shouting at them about
how stupid they've been and how they're
going to be losing all of the money that
has been entrusted to them and as far as
what's public the most part you must
parsimonious explanation is
you guys you three percent if you will
you were wrong right you were wrong
like yeah of course it's possible but
no what we're seeing is evidence of such
deep fraud such deep fraud that is what
we are seeing right now and no that's
not the most part you want is
parsimonious explanation yes that's
evidence of conspiracy but you know what
that's what's going on yeah well and
they were right it is the most
parsimonious but not at that point it
was impossible so what was visible to
the rest of the world right and so
anyway I think you know you and I have
been suffering from this very thing
throughout much of the pandemic where
um just simply following the evidence
where it Led Led to excruciating levels
of pressure from in many cases quite
Close Quarters right you know back off
you're wrong you're killing people all
of these uh claims which of course turn
out to be nonsense it's you know yes the
analysis was difficult but it's not that
difficult right
if you're not responding to the pressure
but in any case the
um
the
I think it has to be described as the
consequence of the cognitive dissonance
that comes from doing exactly the thing
you were trained for right scientific
analysis and having it put you at odds
with all sorts of people who claim that
that's what they're doing
um is uh it it's torture but in the end
reality is what it is nature bats last
and uh you know I fear that they will be
able to drag out a recognition of what
has taken place for many decades
but the truth will out and I'm
pretending that it is other than it
appears to be is no way to live
all right well I think we've gotten
there
um
that means it is
your turn to start moving the tech
around boom and um
we're gonna take a 15 minute break and
this week for the first time in three
weeks we will come back with a live q a
you can ask questions at
darkhorsesmissions.com I forgot to
mention at the top of the hour uh that
our store has some new stuff in it
including pins and it's got darker's
pins now and some other other great
stuff so um check that out if you're
interested in stuff here I've even got
it's not hidden but it was stickers
not we do not sell laptops we can't have
the laptop you have no stickers
um I would just add a member of the
Coalition of the reasonable discussion
suggested
um pins apparently they were already in
the works but
um but pins are a great way to subtly
indicate to others who might also not be
of the uh the enforced perspective that
uh you've been paying attention to Dark
Horse and might be open to a
conversation so anyway the idea of
people finding each other the way they
find us
um and often say marvelous things to us
unexpected moments
um anyway if you find each other that
will be even that much better so
a pin might be a good way of doing that
indeed
uh okay so you can um if you've got
logistical questions as opposed to
questions that you want us to answer you
can email darkhorsemoderator gmail.com
consider joining our patreons consider
getting our book hunter-gatherers guides
the 21st century uh check out my writing
on Natural Selections on my sub stack
and until we see you next time be that
in 15 minutes or a week from now or
sometime later down the road be good to
the ones you love eat good food and get
outside be well everybody